foreign
this is election campaigning Brazil
style
there's no PO face waiting around it's
basically a massive celebration
these are die-hard supporters of Lula de
Silva a former president now bidding to
make a remarkable comeback against the
incumbent Jeb bolsonaro
this is a close fight now a second round
of voting looms at the end of the month
they thought Luda would win outright but
they haven't lost faith deals
they waited in blistering heat for hours
and finally he appeared
helped onto a truck in the beginning of
a chaotic Caravan starting in the same
street where he was arrested on
corruption charges in 2018.
this was the first time he's got back on
the campaign Trail since he failed to
win the first round last Sunday and they
loved it so Lula and his supporters
weren't shocked at losing the first
round it was the fact that bolzanaro did
so well and this is about kick-starting
their campaign as they get near to that
crucial second vote that we'll decide
the next president of Brazil
followed by thousands Lula and his
Entourage and political colleagues wound
their way through the streets yeah
Shoppers and Shop owners watching as
this loud parade made its way to a
nearby Square
[Applause]
you dressed the crowd promising to win
on October the 30th
presidential elections are often won by
the candidate with momentum in truth
president bolsonaro has that momentum
after he confounded the polls and Drew
near to his adversary
Lula needs new momentum this he and his
team hope is the start Stu Ramsey Sky
News Sao Paulo